spoilers there's spoilers for Mario in
this video spoilers
alright not that you should be shocked
to learn that Mario helps save peach in
a Super Mario game but once you finish
the main story peach will take a
well-deserved vacation until the
kingdoms you visited throughout the game
if you come across her in her travel
shoe reward you with a power moon and
give you some clue as to her next
destination but to make it extra easy
we've put together a guide in all the
places you'll find the princess across
her travels
peach starts our travels in the same
place you do in the cap kingdom you'll
find a just past the shop hanging out
with her traveling party tiara and a
very fetching suitcase talk to her to
get your first power moon
in the Cascade Kingdom simply warp to
fossil force Heights and she'll be
hanging out on a cliff edge listening to
the nearby waterfall
to find peach in the sand kingdom you
can walk to toss starina ruins tower
flag and take the electricity wire all
the way to the top of the inverted
pyramid peach and tiara will be hanging
out next to the Jackie statue in the
wooded kingdom walk to iron mountain
path station 8 and head up the ramp
activate the P block and platform your
way up to the top the tower to find
peach on top taking in the view with
another power moon view
features real easy to find in the late
Kingdom just walk to water Plaza Terrace
and she'll be at the top of the stairs
watching the waves
the cloud Kingdom is pretty small so
it's extra easy to find beach just head
up the cloud platforms and you'll see
are on the edge taking in the scenery
peach maybe doing a spot of shopping in
the lost kingdom as you can find her
hanging out next to the crazy cap store
warp to Rocky Mountain summit and she'll
be waiting for you there
once arriving in the Metro Kingdom warp
to the rooftop garden use the electrical
wire to get between buildings and use
the orange posts and boxes to reach the
top of tower feature be there waiting to
give you another power moon in the snow
kingdom you'll need to head to chivalry
a town warp to above the ice well
checkpoint and head down the whole
future be in the stands down the hall
waiting for the races to start
to find peach in the seaside kingdom
you'll have to travel up one of the
water spouts sat on the shore do that
and you'll be launched into the sky and
land helpfully next the princess
the luncheon kingdom is hosting a
celebration after powers of defeat you
can find peach and prawns a Plaza she'll
be just past the shop next the big vat
of stew waiting for her serving
the ruined Kingdom is also quite small
so peaches again easy to find
you just have to head back up to where
you fix the dragon which is thankful
he's still sleeping and peach should be
there keeping the reptile company
leaving no kingdom out peach even
explores Bowser's kingdom warp to the
souvenir shop and she'll be standing
with tiara just outside peach will be
above the church where she was nearly
hitched when she returns to the moon
kingdom to find her go behind the church
possess the frog and climb onto the roof
of the chapel pgb taking in the sights
just under the church bells
and of course peach returns the Mushroom
Kingdom after her travels are complete
looking across her domain from the
balcony to get the balcony head behind
the castle to the nearby scarecrow and
throw your cap at it to spawn the stairs
use those to get to the roof and then
you can easily jump down to create the
princess and claim your last power moon
so that's everywhere you can find
Princess Peach after she heads off on a
well-deserved holidays we also have a
video where you can find all the hidden
paintings in the games - be sure to
check that out so you can be sure to
find every Power Moon for more Mario and
everything else make sure you stay tuned
to Gamescom
[Music]